uh you know what I appreciate about you
is like one of the early things that had
happened in La when I first moved out
here was you and Greedo did the first
verses correct definitely the first
verses
it was at the novo
correct and the observatory are you
interested you guys did do too the first
one was at the novo though right um the
first one was Adam services oh she see
the first one was they thought everybody
was gonna die
yeah I mean I remember talking ahead and
he's like I'm not gonna be there and I
was like we should go and I'm like you
know what I'm gonna listen to anything
La related I just listened to head on
I'm like you know what you're right head
yeah and it was a success you know it
was so dope because I remember y'all
going back and forth online and then you
guys had this [ __ ] incredible event
where everybody was on stage right and
it just felt like wow this is like this
is like history low-key for sure it was
basically like you know it was what
Gucci and Jeezy did
but we did it because our show was more
like in the mo in the in the in the
moment it was in the moment that's what
made it different yeah for sure and the
fact that there was no incidents is
amazing yeah for sure when did you guys
talk like before it went down like was
there like a little meet up backstage
that Ayla we'll keep respectful we'll
make sure no we didn't know what was
gonna happen what the [ __ ] no I was
gonna whoop his ass it was just
organized chaos but then we just like
you know kept it cool and I'll just plan
we we talked about it yeah no we talked
about it um on the phone because it got
out of hand it got out of hand on the
um like on the internet right internet
you know always blows things over
proportion and you know when you don't
have communication you know it [ __ ] up
the nation so you know we talked about
are we uh uh shout out
um oh noses also an artist my phone
excuse my fault I said my father enough
that he's also the artist from amio
um but you know he's always been around
you don't know so yeah uh but him and
Mafia horn they got involved and you
know they Mafia horn talked to Greedo
knows to talk to me and we got on the
phone and when we got on the phone it
was like you know it was it was like
that you know what I'm saying initially
yeah but you know they talked to us
talk some sense into us and then we you
know I'm saying we we carry out the show
and it kept it going because it's really
bigger than us yeah sometimes you know
being in the moments you don't
understand that sometimes being in the
beef you don't understand that
um it's bigger than you
you got the Focus right now people own
you right now they perpetuating this
beef they perpetuating it and making it
blow up but it's bigger than you you
know it's more it's about y'all a hole
you feel me what both of y'all represent
and it could be detrimental so like
sometimes you gotta rise above yourself
and rise above the situation and really
like see yourself above it and see the
whole game and look at yourself from a
bird's eye view and you know being moved
up move accordingly you know what I'm
saying so that's what we did we just
seen ourselves first off you and moved
accordingly and we made money off that
[ __ ] that was like my first fifty
thousand dollar show wow okay you got me
50 bands off the show
I did [ __ ] shout out to you what's a
good [ __ ] day for sure that's a great
day
what's up was that the Nova we got two
of them Jesus
salute for sure